if you're gonna tell you know ozzy's
story and
you said you you've told versions of
this before or parts of this before
but if you're gonna tell the story you
have to tell the whole story because
you would expect nothing less and that
includes the the sort of good the rock
star moments but also the bad and the
extremely dark
was there any hesitation at your dad's
present place in life and at the age
that he is and even with your mom
that maybe we just don't want to go over
all of that
again yeah there were there were some
things that you know that we that we
kind of pulled back on a little bit
and um but it's that balance it's that
you know we would be and i it was there
was a time where we weren't going to
mention
the accident or the or the parkinson's
diagnosis
um and i basically said well we're going
to be lying
like we're making this film let's use
this opportunity to
tell the whole truth and i don't want it
to bite us in the ass because
we're not sure if it's the right time
like this is the perfect opportunity
because we can control the narrative
and and that's kind of that's that's why
we
we actually went back and um we had to
reopen the edit and
do a couple days of more filming after
he got diagnosed with uh
you know parkinson's and was kind of
comfortable talking about it
when when it's both of your parents in
involved in some of these stories
and your mom tells the story of
your dad on a bender and sitting in
front of her and the words that he said
to her while looking her in the eye
right before he tried to strangle her
what does that what is that like for you
to hear that story retold
you know it's it's something that you
can i kind of
obviously was aware of my whole life
that it happened and
um it's you know it's i
i i think when i look at it from the
perspective of like those of my parents
and that happened
it's really kind of
you know me saying that yeah when you
look at it from
you know but when you're producing a
documentary you kind of have to look at
it from
a story perspective and you know it's
it's it's something that is a part of
the journey and and
we we would be doing ourselves no favor
if we were kind of um making this like a
squeaky clean
and they all lived happily ever after
film because it's not the truth
what's your relation what is it sorry
what's your what's your
relationship like now with cameras and
allowing cameras
into sort of your lives after having
done the after having done the
the the osborne's and really president
what's that what's the family's
relationship of all sitting down
together now
as a family again in front of cameras um
it's something that you know we just
we we've been my parents filmed another
series
just over quarantined osborne's want to
believe and it's the travel channel and
it's where we review paranormal
caught on camera tape and discuss it and
um it's you know for me i feel a lot
more comfortable
when i have control of what is being
filmed
and it's not because
i'm necessarily it's i guess maybe comes
down to being a bit of a control freak
in the sense that that like
i won't misrepresent or you know
turn a scene into something that
actually wasn't and i
you know and so i have a lot of fear
about you know the magic of
of of tv editing um and so
it there is an element of insecurity
but is if i'm in control of it i'm fine
i'm wondering when you watch this and
you and we we know the story of your of
your mom and dad so well and everything
that they've been through
and are still together i'm wondering how
that affected you how are you
with resolving conflict how are you with
getting over
things how are you with forgiving how
are you with moving on
yeah you know i think i move on pretty
quick like i'm not one of these people
that
will sit there and like i just don't
you know it's like i don't i don't have
i try to kind of process through
resentment and i try to kind of
get it gone because it doesn't do any
favors you know it's
you know my my primary goal you know
as a human is to like take care of my
kids and work and just like
focus on you know i don't have time for
sitting there and
having gripes against people like even
people that i've like
had really bad falling outs with and you
know if i see him
i'm i don't i don't care enough because
they're not it's not my priority
uh there's a there's a moment where you
talk about um ozzy where
he was not on the road and he wasn't
touring anymore
and you point to the fact that he's just
not him
when he's not on the road he can't be
that thing where you just stay inside
all day he has to have a stage what has
this been like what is
isolation been like for your dad i can't
imagine
he's doing well with this no it's been i
mean listen it's it's been a
blessing and a curse in the sense that
you know he's been recovering from a bad
fall
so it's there's been the great thing is
all pressure has been removed to like
got to get back on your feet because
you've got these tour dates to hit
you've got to get
out here and do this and that so there's
no pressure
which is good but it's also bad because
if there's no pressures i'm not gonna
take my time getting better
um but he's he's doing okay you know
we're on vacation right now they
they're off they rented a house up in
santa barbara so i'm i'm up here for the
for the week hanging out and you know
he's swimming every day and
he's hanging out with my kids and yeah
he's he's doing okay
there's i think there's uh you know
there are much worse places you can be
uh quarantined right now
um the the the part of the documentary
they they ask him
if it's true that he snorted ants which
is featured in the
the dirt movie on netflix and uh and and
in the book and his reaction was i don't
know i might have
yeah and it's funny
he he will he often says he's like i
don't
even know he's like i mean if it
happened it'd happen if it didn't i
don't know
i mean it was not it's like it's not
though those years aren't known his
as his most coherent years so right
and if you guys were because i know that
there's been talk so much talk over the
years
about doing an aussie biopic um sort of
like a
a film version of his life is that going
to happen at all do you think does he
want it
i i yes he does and i will say that it
is in active development
it is can't say where can't say who's
involved yet because you know i have to
let the
the people who uh a lot more powerful
than me make uh that announcement but um
there are um it is an active development
and what's his involvement in it how
active is he in this
he's he's not he doesn't you know just
like the doc he's just like
show it to me when it's done and i'll
let you know if i like it
you